bienvenue en seine saint denis au pays
du béton et du chômage en exclusivité le
premier habitant du 9-3 à gravir
l'himalaya mais marché pendant un mois
c'est la seule idée de taille dans la
vessie je veux dire je vais marcher tout
moment je vais pas partir avec des
bombes ou moins mais depuis quand une
dispute avec la mère part j'aimerais
poser la question que tout le monde se
pose pourquoi tu fais ça
nadia samir fermé cassure ferait
n'importe quoi pour toi je montre même
les vrais sifaoui s'est montrée
l'everest d'hilton merde
je vois surtout on sait dès que tu as
fait le mont blanc ah mais c'est quand
même pas l'aide du mont-blanc des cornes
ou quoi hakim ullah paix avec ça sur la
dalle enfants klezmer away en plus il
faisait beau et kilimandjaro dans la
face nord
un peu toutes les faces
mon boulot c'est de vous emmener en au
sérieux jamais on s'arrête là si on
attend encore 50 ans il y aura peut-être
un téléphérique pour aller jusqu'aux ça
va je plaisante pas mater et mater toute
la journée porte comme ça
quand ils carburent cela c'est pas
possible un frigo les gars
comment tu as gagné combien pour monter
sa cage mais thibault damour tout bien
et ça même pas de membres huit jeunes la
connaissent
c'est quoi cette galère la joue pas pour
faire des profits en quoi la moi
j'habite au 6ème étage sans ascenseur il
n'y a pas un mec qui montrait pont rouge
la chasse
ça m'étonnerait il est déjà parti
arrêtes tu déconnes cette galère
j'espère que tu es fier de toi at il dit
de partir là bas
nadia c'est moi je t'ai dit que ferait
n'importe quoi pour tout bas ça y est je
crois que suis vraiment en train de
faire n'importe quoi alors on se veut
j en profite pour passer un petit coucou
à ma famille mes parents mes frères et
soeurs
il n'a dit un seul tour
c'est un gros big up à tous ceux qui me
soutiennent au quartier ailleurs
mais s'il est vrai qu'en fait
normalement c'est vers l'est et vers s
tiens j'ai endossé à manon sont subis
les semaines passent et ça me saoule à
l'air vicieux qui c'est qui va sur un
bonbon qui tue pas tes potes qui s'est
donnée un club à ce niveau tous me
coller aux cures salut yak